before we get started tonight you might
notice my voice is shot I was at the
Eagles game yesterday so don't worry I'm
not sick I'm sick of winning
we'll have more in the Eagles later on
the show but now for this
staying at a hotel is great somebody
makes the bed for you fresh towels every
day and room service
[Music]
this is occasion
Two Scoops here two make it three I'm
not driving no matter how much fun
you're having you can't stay at a hotel
forever but don't tell that to the
migrants here in New York the mayor's
been putting up illegals in Swanky
hotels that cost up to 500 a night
now he's trying to kick him out but the
migrants don't want to go
[Applause]
let me Translate
the city is trying to send them to a
different taxpayer-funded shelter but
they got used to a life of luxury the
hotel they're in now has a pool gym TVs
dry cleaning a restaurant bar and lounge
they don't want to go somewhere that
doesn't have those types of amenities
so so the Brooklyn Cruise terminal is a
large structure it's not meant to be
inhabited it is a thousand beds beds
made out of hard material there's no
space for personal belongings if you
have personal belongings you have to put
them in a locker that's out of your
control there's only four bathrooms for
a thousand men which is unsustainable uh
for anybody who's working it's in an
isolated part of the city away from
where many of them work and it's cold
when someone else is paying you don't
get to choose where your room is
this is not like taking someone out to
dinner or where she can just choose
whatever she wants from the menu this is
like when you're staying over at
someone's house if they tell you to
sleep on the couch you sleep on the
couch
if they say you're having chicken for
dinner you're not having steak
our rules our house we pay the bills
and it's a big Bill at least a million a
month just for the hotels and now the
migrants extended check out how extended
how long are we paying for the migrants
to live for free in Times Square hotels
until Easter
until next Easter forever they should be
thankful they're not getting deported
we had a President Who deported migrants
and built hotels and now we have a
president who Imports migrants and pays
for their hotels
these migrants that were shacking up
aren't even families you heard the guy
they're single men
so ladies if you're interested they're
staying at the Watson
and they're giving the rest of the
migrants a bad rap
they come here saying they want to work
and then protests that they don't get
free rent
I guess they're assimilating quickly
they're already protesting and trashing
hotel rooms
I mean if you want to stay in Times
Square get naked and grab a guitar
people will pay you
sure Brooklyn's not Martha's Vineyard
but it beats wherever they came from
they left shiny towns
where they claim they feared for their
lives crawled through jungles marched
through deserts to get here and now
they're Drawing the Line at Brooklyn
they're from Venezuela and they don't
want to go to Brooklyn
we're giving them free food free rent
and beds on the Brooklyn Waterfront
the definition of Migrant is to move
from one place to another but now
they're done moving
they traveled 3 000 miles to come here
and now they don't want to go one more
mile
the migrants want to stay at this luxury
hotel and pay for it by defunding the
police
the immediate resolution is that the
hotel Watson needs to accept these men
back and put them back into their rooms
the longer term solution is that to
reallocate funding from overfunded
departments like the NYPD into housing
vouchers and other programs that get
people into permanent stable housing
these migrants have been getting moved
all over New York City ever since they
were bussed here the mayor can't figure
out what to do with them first he stuck
them in the Bronx but then the residents
got really upset
this is you know this is kind of
shocking I'm concerned with my safety
there's a park right over there kids go
to play in that Park so that worries me
why would they do this why not house
them elsewhere
they take our money and they do whatever
they want with it so much money and help
is being put out there for other people
that are coming into this country but
not much is being put into the people
that live in this country and then the
mayor built a shelter on an island and
stuck them there he gave them Xboxes and
popcorn machines and fluff and fold
laundry service even culturally
appropriate snacks um
also be snacks that are provided coffee
tea water 24 hours a day and those meals
are all culturally appropriate it is a
South American Fair
but that wasn't good enough so the mayor
put them up in hotels
and then the migrants trash the rooms
they drank all day smoked weed had sex
in the staircase got in fights
and then the migrants tossed all the
free food in the garbage and set up
makeshift kitchens in their rooms even
though their hot plates were fire
hazards they wanted more culturally
appropriate snacks
we're cooking for them now I thought
they were here to cook for us isn't that
what the San Antonio Sheriff said
if you go to any restaurant in San
Antonio Texas right now you're gonna
wait a long time to get your table even
though there's Empty Tables because
there's not enough weight staff to wait
on you there you're going to wait a long
time for your food because there's not
enough people to to cook it in the back
half the cooks maybe aren't aren't
showing up to work or they've quit hire
these folks the only place that's a
bigger mess in these hotel rooms is the
Border look at this video from Texas
Troopers spotted a group of illegals
bailing out of a Smuggler's pickup truck
watch
23.
2005. they're bailing they're bailing
then The Smuggler hit the gas hit about
110 miles an hour and then went off the
road
uh we'll be out good spot uh 1050
rollover
foreign
[Music]
the police found a handgun on The
Smuggler after the arrest
they just made it a little farther north
they would have gotten there culturally
appropriate meals
and in Mission Texas border patrol found
a group of illegals disguised as
cyclists biking around the Border
what's going on here did the migrants
not realize there's an app
you might have heard about Biden's app
for illegals it lets them make a
reservation for when they want to break
into the country let's check in with how
that's going
new appointments are available every day
starting at 6 a.m but the vast amount of
people trying to apply is overwhelming
the system many aren't able to log in
while some who do say the app crashes
before they're able to confirm their
appointment some complainants say but I
don't even have a cell phone sadly they
do need a cell phone an email to
communicate so it's busted the app
crashes all the time and there's no open
appointments it's easier just to walk
through the Border oh and apparently
Biden's app for illegals is racist
if you're dark-skinned and submit a
photo of yourself you get an error
message
critics say the app has issues detecting
the photos some applicants use personas
problems with people of African descent
having difficulty taking the photo the
app is not recognizing the photos of
these people so we have Africans coming
now
what's the root cause of that Kamala I
thought this was all about Central
America not the entire world flying to
Mexico to break in
so where is our borders are
she needs to shut down this broken
racist app right now treat it like mayor
Pete treats racist Bridges
but she's too busy fighting for her
political life even Democrats are
turning on Kamala Pocahontas
doesn't think it's time for a new VP
if he's that old in the second term that
vice presidency becomes even more
important because she Kamala Harris be
that his choice the second time around
you know I I really want to defer to
what makes Biden comfortable on his team
I've known Kamala for a long time I like
Kamala I knew her back when she was when
she was an attorney general and I was
still uh teaching and we worked on the
housing crisis together so we go way
back but they need they have to be a
team
Kamal and I go way back but Biden should
get rid of her
an incumbent president hasn't dumped
their VP since the 1940s when FDR is
fourth term dumped
uh who cares and Pocahontas is ready to
toss out Kamala what's going on here hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else